if you weren't acting what would you be
doing let's suppose that just for some
reason you said you know what I'm gonna
take a break organic farm on man okay so
here's the thing I I don't know maybe
something with martial arts but i never
have a back-up plan because i think it
gives me like that certain little air
bubble of like the possibility I could
fail so I've never really had a back-up
plan so I've never really try to think
about it because I don't want to think
that I would ever have to do anything
else hopefully you know knock on wood
somewhere that I could do this for the
rest of my life it makes me happy i love
being on set I love creating in general
i love you know whether it's doing a
short you know with your friends in
their backyard or doing a movie you're
dependent film like this or doing a
studio film or being on TV it's any day
I get to act is awesome why do you want
it so bad ah man there there are a lot
of reasons I because because it makes me
happy and you feel like you have to get
to a certain place to where you can be
doing it to the I guess extent that I
want to do it I want to be able to one
day hopefully be able to pick what I do
you know I mean I am as like ninety-nine
point nine percent of actors are I'm you
know part of that audition grind I want
it so bad because one day I want to be
able to go you know I really want to do
this I really want to do this and at
least my name be in the discussion uh
you know even if i select audition for
it if it's you know if I'm on their
their top list of people that would be
really cool but I want to be able to do
what i want one day so I think that's
probably the main reason I wanted really
really badly so bad how many actors do
you know that are in that space that
that have that pick and choose sort of
like personally ah like one or two like
not not many you know and even friends I
have what I would consider like
killing it the soft audition they're
just you know at a like a different
level of it they're like in the
discussion you know in the short on ppl
shortlist for a project but I mean it's
a very small group of people
you